you know it was about the asian attack
stuff right so lo and behold somebody
dm's me
yeah and somebody i follow is china mac
right you know what china matches right
big-ass [ __ ] chinese rapper rapper
right yeah
and it was interesting because i was i
haven't listened to a lot of chinamax
music right
but i have listened to a couple he has
he has one with uh dave east that's
really dope
okay and chinamaking [ __ ] rap yeah
there's not a lot of like
asian rappers that i i personally enjoy
a lot but he's one of them where it's
like
he in five four three two
one yeah it's recording what's up
everybody
welcome to another episode of the genius
brain
podcast we have edrick park back in the
house
right now it's a battle of the ed's
there's ed park
and there's nothing don't get it twisted
man all right this guy this guy gets
confused too
like sometimes on the thing i just put i
actually [ __ ] up both your guys's titles
and i
switch you guys all the time yeah what
you been doing
uh it's just continuing to live that
cope with life bro
what else can i do you know you got
vaccinated i did i did how [ __ ] lucky
you don't look like you're 65 yeah i got
lucky with it um
so i mean but more than anything it's uh
my parents getting vaccinated is
what really gives me peace of mind
because that should have me paranoid you
know
yeah like just getting situation getting
worse and worse and here's the crazy
[ __ ]
like it's gotten better better right
and people are saying oh look you know
the numbers are dropping
yeah but the numbers just dropped to
summer levels in 2020. that's not
anything to say
yeah yeah i mean that's that's like when
it was really starting to get bad
so it's like it's crazy here in america
because
the smallest amount of drop in numbers
is like a reason to celebrate all right
yeah yeah go out now we can go back to
normal
when do you think uh we'll probably get
back to normal oh not until 2022
[ __ ] at the earliest for sure it's so
long
yeah but look at it bro look at the
people here in america even if they can
get vaccinated which they'll be able to
by summer
everybody will be able to get it without
any restrictions it's like
what i don't i don't know the exact
number but i
if i were to guess i would say maybe
like a third or less
a little less than don't want to get
vaccinated
you know what i mean why don't why are
people so apprehensive is it because
they feel like it's not tested enough
yet and something's going to happen to
them one
one big thing is politics right is
is like these uh ex-trumpers or i i
guess not even x ex-trumpers still
current trumpers
feel like not president yeah like
wearing a mask
socially distancing vaccinating is all
like you being a snowflake in a beta
yeah yeah yeah which is [ __ ]
ridiculous it's like that's the wildest
[ __ ] ever
um i don't understand that at all well i
remember when the
the vaccine first came out well this is
what i'm saying like media
is is so interesting right they put out
these
these [ __ ] fluff pieces or whatever
the [ __ ] it is right these exaggerated
pieces where
they go oh well people who there's
somebody who got the vaccine and this
and x amount of things happened or
whatever but they don't ever talk about
the probability of
you know all vaccines have side effects
right and
they start doing this stuff just to make
people worry because it's going to get
the article's views
yeah right but literally all my friends
in the medical field
have gotten the vaccine now first and
second shot and i'm talking about a
hundred percent of them they've all been
okay right
a hundred and i like i'm not i don't
know a [ __ ] ton of people who are
doctors
but doctors nurses teachers everybody
who's getting a shot right now yeah a
hundred percent of them and that's
probably
i'd say at least like 15 or 60 people
that i know that have gotten the
the shot and has zero side effects yeah
i mean the thing is
even even if you do have the side
effects because
now i have uh some friends who've gotten
their second rounds already
and some of them have talked about
getting like a fever
and like oh yeah yeah you know but
that's a small price
okay one day of that versus possible
death or like some permanent
um you know loss of taste or like losing
some sense
that you have i mean if the trade-off is
easily
worth it um yeah when my brother got it
he said that he had what
he had like a fever for a day and then
the next day he was fine
yeah i'll take that [ __ ] you guys don't
want that [ __ ] for sure for sure but
you know you have politics involved in
it and yes you do have those
anti-vaxxers and then you just have
people who are skeptical
just skeptical of it like uh is it safe
if i get it am i gonna
experience any side effects short term
and long give those anti-vaxxers some
aids see
see how they feel it's like we have the
vaccine for aids like no we're good man
i'm good i don't believe in that [ __ ]
i'm just gonna have my apple cider
vinegar yeah
and i'll be okay you [ __ ] i'm just
gonna die an early death it's fine
oh did you hear [ __ ] um this is this
doesn't actually come as a shock to
not not so much as a shock but i wasn't
really affected like other people were
but daft punk splitting
yeah that was uh that was crazy it was
completely out of the blue
and did you see the video yeah i did the
video was so [ __ ] obscure
how the [ __ ] did people know that they
broke up from that [ __ ] like when i saw
it
what it looked like he murdered his best
friend so i didn't know that they were
split from there why are you moving your
foot back
[Applause]
[Laughter]
yeah no but uh it was crazy it was crazy
like because it just happened out of the
blue
and everybody's kind of speculating as
to why
they would split because you know the
thing is like if they decided to split
and it was just kind of like a internal
decision between them of like
yeah you know what we did our thing uh
and let's just you know kind of end it
let's just
go out on top so to speak or maybe it
was uh
really messy maybe they were trying to
work on a project and they
could not agree on it which i doubt
considering how long
their history together has been they've
been together since when early 90s yeah
it's been a long time a long time
yeah the 90s for sure yeah multiple
grammys
the the weird thing is like i don't i
didn't know about okay that's not true i
knew about daft punk but i didn't know
how uh popular they were oh yeah until
the pharrell album oh the random access
memories album
exactly get lucky single from there
exactly yeah yeah with
niles rogers exactly so when i when i
heard that [ __ ] and you know
they were doing the collab with daft
punk i've heard of them before yeah but
obviously the sound of that album was
completely different right it was
it was hip-hop it was edm it was all
this other stuff um
but i didn't realize how huge of a cult
following that they had yeah dude
and i also didn't know that nobody knows
what they look like since like the early
90s
yeah yeah i mean they've uh they're
they're one of the
i guess like groups or artists
um who did an impeccable job with their
branding
because it just stayed consistent
throughout their whole career
and yes the the whole robot thing the
image of it and everything evolved over
time but it was
always on brand with what they were
trying to do um
and bro they were they were hugely
influential you know what
i mean look at her kanye's stronger
track right that was simple
yeah that's right well it was daft punk
sampled a song and kanye
sampled the sample right so um but yeah
that's that's what it is based off of
oh they they're they're what they're
parisian no yeah yeah parisian yeah they
are that's [ __ ] crazy man like
i feel like when people talk about daft
punk
[Music]
i think it's hard for people to i think
when i was reading online they're like
oh my god daft punk broke
like broke up i kind of wanted to ask
these people like what's that [ __ ]
daft punk song that you know [ __ ]
like besides the one besides the [ __ ]
from kanye and pharrell yeah
what's the daft punk song that you know
cause sometimes i feel like online
people are very disingenuous about the
stuff that they like
only because people are are like blowing
it up that they feel like they have to
put their two cents
you know what the thing is is that they
the reason why
like even the new generation knows daft
punk is because they
they were able to stay relevant by
working with big artists like at the
weekend
right i feel like coming uh star boy
right those are that oh that was
definitely yeah
that's that punk [ __ ] yeah maybe i'm
just a hater then yeah
so so i mean you know
that's how they've been able to stay
relevant throughout the decades
is just them making dope ass music as
always
and then them also collaborating with
other huge artists at that time
so because they definitely have to be in
their 40s yeah
i would say yeah specifically only they
specifically only did edm right yeah
yeah electronic music there's no vocals
there's no nothing like that
so no they did they did so they would
use a vocoder that's kind of like their
signature thing
they would sample but here's the [ __ ]
though bro they would sample like funk
records and stuff
you know what i mean oh [ __ ] yeah and
then and then turn that into basically
electronic music
and before edm music was like what
people know idiom music as now like with
these all these huge festivals and [ __ ]
back then is when they had the cult
following and then like going into the
2000s they just started to get huge
from that point on yeah and then ever
since then they've kind of been a
household name in a sense
without being in the public eye all the
time that's
the craziest very hard to do it is
that's why i was thinking about it i was
like
wait i don't even know what they look
like yeah i actually had to google it
and i found an
old picture of them from the early 90s
which clearly they don't look like that
anymore
but since before or after that there
aren't any published photos
of their face yeah so i don't who knows
what they look like yeah that video was
so weird and jarring because it was it
was even done with like the uh
the soundtrack of like a like an 80s
kung fu movie or some [ __ ] you know what
i mean
like those 80s like cop movies or some
[ __ ] yeah and it was so weird because
when i was looking at it
i'm like how did people surmise that
they broke up from this like he
literally blew one of them up i know i
know but but i think it was one of those
things where like
oh is are they trying to say this and
then they confirm with the publicist
the public is confirmed yes you know
they they have broken up that [ __ ] has
like 21 million views
yeah dude but that's that's how big of a
following that they have
i mean honestly in this day and age
though i guess 21 million is not even
like astronomical numbers you got like
these k-pop bands who are doing like 300
million
in a week you know what i mean oh
freaking now what's his face i just saw
the numbers today because uh bobby
schmurder just got out
from jail ethel's uh song
the one that he uh the one that he got
really popular off of uh
[ __ ] well i'm i'm blanking out right now
but either way everybody does the dance
yeah this
[ __ ] dance half a [ __ ] billion
views dude 600 something million or
something like that
no there are videos that are in the
billions of views now i
i've i've been seeing that i mean i'm
sure it's existed but
i've only personally been seeing it for
the first time in like the past month
and i'm like holy [ __ ] is this a billion
views
that's definitely size gangnam style has
a million views yeah i i would
i would say i think that's a safe bet to
say he has a billion views i haven't
seen
you know with that video in a long time
i didn't know that i didn't even know
that bobby smyrda was in jail
he was in jail for [ __ ] like six
years holy [ __ ] he fell off
or what i think it's like racketeering
and all that other [ __ ] but he was like
gang affiliated
i mean he had a couple of priors yeah
before he got
in jail with this one but i guess like
his music group um he calls it a media
group but they're considered i guess the
police consider them a gang
or some [ __ ] like that right but it was
like he's doing dumb [ __ ]
yeah don't don't quote me on this it was
like racketeering murder yeah just a
typical [ __ ] like that bro you you're an
artist now man you can make some money
you know doing that you don't got to do
all that illegal [ __ ] anymore
he did a bid for like six six seven
years and i i think like he had to
negotiate that down
but he negotiated down where it was like
him and his associate
they were only going to do time for
seven years together okay um
i guess people respected that a lot
because he didn't stitch you know
conversely like takashi six nine where
he switched on his own
so it was like a huge [ __ ] thing
everybody's celebrating his release like
cuevo everybody's tweeting it out yeah
it's kind of nuts man i don't think the
the thought that you can go to jail for
six or seven years after you had a
pop-in record
you made all this [ __ ] uh money off
of music and at the time when he first
started rapping or performing
and this is him this is six seven years
ago this is him just starting off like
each show he was making a minimum of
like 20 grand
yeah like 20k each for a young person
like that for each show and he was
touring a lot
and he went to jail for some stupid [ __ ]
like that just like man
i always wondered too it's like ha ha i
can't do that like if i'm already making
money legitimately
what's the point exactly well i guess
it's i guess it's hard because
like when that's kind of their
background
and that's their life i mean it's like
you either move out of the hood or you
stay in the hood
right yeah and really depends on the
person
people some people who you know were
aspiring artists who get to that level
of becoming kind of like you know an
artist that's made
they're like dude why why why the [ __ ]
would i stay in the hood that's this is
why i've been hustling this is what i've
been grinding to get myself in a better
life you know away from all this [ __ ]
but then you got
especially if they're younger maybe they
don't have that
perspective and kind of like life
experience and they're like
you know i ain't a [ __ ] man i'm in the
hood for life you know
is this this what i'm about and if
that's the case then obviously
you're not going to be able to stay out
of trouble there's some like scary
people like
so the the other day too i was looking
through my dms and i did that video
where uh you know it was about the asian
attack stuff right
so lo and behold somebody dm's me yeah
and if somebody i follow is china mac
right you know what china is right big
ass [ __ ] chinese rapper rapper
right yeah and it was interesting
because i was
i haven't listened to a lot of china max
music right um but i have listened to a
couple he has
he has one with uh dave east that's
really dope okay and china mac and
[ __ ] rap
yeah there's not a lot of like asian
rappers that i i
personally enjoy a lot but he's one of
them where it's like
he he like raps with a lot of conviction
and he is he's about what he says right
right i mean he he's done his time too
exactly and so when he when he messaged
me i want to get him on this podcast but
i'm pretty sure if he comes on this
podcast he probably told
everything already online but i'm just
kind of curious about other stuff that
people haven't asked
but he is such an interesting character
because i i went to go
see his channel and it's gone
his youtube channel is completely gone
why uh and then i went back to his
instagram to look
through a few things so apparently china
mac deleted his youtube and his music
off of all of his platforms itunes
spotify or whatever
or if it's still on spotify i'm not sure
what's happening with that right
but uh he went online and he did this um
a youtube live because i asked a couple
of other people where he was talking
about he's quitting music forever
like he's done with [ __ ] music and he
kind of went on this diatribe about
getting people to understand why it's
so hard to be an independent artist
because a lot of people don't see the
cost
that it takes to make this specific
piece of art but a lot of people are
asking for more content but they're not
willing to pay for the stuff that they
see so china mac was talking about well
there's just um there's this music video
that i did
uh it goes i had to rent out the
the prisoner guard outfits i had to run
out the truck the music video people the
producers heals basically what happens
with music
the music producer the the album artists
the the uh the the people on set
whatever the pas everybody gets to check
before me and the artist gets the last
check
everybody wants me to continue music you
guys verbally say that you support me
but i'm out here i don't have any
[ __ ] money so
where's the support so he's like i'm
pretty much done with music i got to do
something that feeds me
and i think like his fans had like this
weird weird reaction to a part of it was
like hey you'll keep your head up like
keep doing this [ __ ] make it a hustle
but other fans kind of felt that yo
you're kind of dissing us like we
we're supporting you what about the fans
that do support you which i kind of
understood
his standpoint you know where i think
now because everybody gets a cut of what
whatever you do it's hard for him to
survive as an artist
i just don't understand though why he
would take down all his content i mean
why not just i mean yeah you could quit
music but i don't i don't understand
kind of the
mentality of removing everything
after he did that and the only reason
why i found out that he removed his
music was because
he put up a post on his instagram where
he was talking about
um he's actually doing
the thing that you did where it's
distributing music
out personally versus putting it through
other platforms oh i see
so and uh that was per advice of some of
his friends or some of his friends in
the industry in the music industry was
like yo
why don't you just distribute your music
directly for people if you have a fan
base that's strong enough yeah
to go ahead and distribute your music
directly to them and that's how you can
make that check
if people really [ __ ] with you if they
say that they verbally [ __ ] with right
then they'll buy your music right you
know directly
which was kind of interesting and i
guess like that's he decided to do music
again he's re-releasing his albums and
selling it out that way hmm
okay okay so it's just kind of like
retooling himself to figure out how how
can i monetize this better or how can i
focus it a little bit
yeah i see that makes sense then yeah um
for me it was the other way around where
like
if for the first i i forget how however
much time it was whether it was like
a few months or whatever yeah it was the
only way you'd be able to access the
music was through the website and
basically getting
digital or physical or both from from
that channel
and then once kind of like that so it
was kind of planned out that way where
like the first wave is going to be from
there
and then once kind of momentum starts to
slow down start slowly putting it on
these other platforms whether it be your
youtubes your sound clouds
your spot and and kind of regenerate
interest again bring it to new audiences
that was kind of the goal with that um
but now in this day and age i mean
because bro think about it that [ __ ] was
already like
five six years ago yeah how much things
have changed since
yeah right i mean you and i were just
talking about it before we started this
with nfts
right and and digital art how how that's
gonna be a game changer and yeah we're
gonna you know we'll save that
conversation for when we have
you know our special guest for that but
the game is different now man it's
different
you know it's and it's just one of those
things where it's like
you can be an artist sure and you could
you could create
what you're good at creating but you
have to understand
also how you're going to distribute this
using all the tools that are available
in the online space for you to maximize
you being an artist
and you being able to make a living as
an artist and if you're not with that
now we're not at a time where people
because back in the days people were
like oh i'm just an artist
i don't want to have to deal with the
business [ __ ] let my manager deal with
it you don't have a manager
okay well i'm going to get a manager so
they can deal with it yeah
now you have to kind of wear multiple
hats in that in that regard
you can't just be an artist artist you
have to you really have to understand
the business side of it
at least if you want to be independent
anyway and there's more than enough
tools out there
to stay independent but it's a different
kind of hustle it's a different kind of
grind now you know what i mean like
if you're a music artist it's not just
about oh being in the studio and just
pumping out
five mixtapes like like the wheezy model
right just pumping out mixtapes every
couple of months and pushing that [ __ ]
out
it's like yeah back then you still had
people
well i'm sure in certain parts of the
the country too they still do it but
like
pushing it out the trunk of the car all
these bootleggers you you get it out to
them
and then these leaks that you create
right and then people get their hands on
it and
spread it all around but it ain't just
like that anymore you know what i mean
the game has changed so much and if you
aren't up to date with that
you evolve or die yeah it's really that
simple and
it's a shame for some talented artists
who die because they don't evolve
yeah and i think for him too when he was
talking about on some of these videos
and i'm pretty sure those videos got
taken down but somebody sent me a
i asked a couple people if they had the
video so i could see him talking about
it
and i think for him it was just i think
it was very disheartening right
especially because of his past life like
i like
i mean i might be wrong about all this
information because i read about him
years ago right
but he did a bid for about 10 years
for attempt for attempted murder yeah
the guy didn't die i think the person
that
he shot actually got paralyzed right and
so
when he for somebody to kind of change
his life around and do something in the
positive way
but then obviously you know having to
reform yourself you have an idea of what
you want to happen if it doesn't happen
that way you get a little disappointed
yeah kind of you know
it's very disheartening and especially
for him he did what he did a bid for
10 years at rikers because he for
attempted murder it was over some
[ __ ] thuggish ass [ __ ] too so
i guess for chyna mack years
he he got somebody stabbed him right and
he was out in public he was with one of
his homies and
in his mind he he told himself that he
ever sees the person who stabs who
stabbed him he's just gonna [ __ ] murk
him on the spot yeah that's him he had
he had a piece on him at
all times yeah right and so he sees the
dude
he's about to blast his dude on site
homie comes and steps in front of me
goes eight not right here it's a very
public area
they didn't really get to release this
penta progression anger and it's it's
mulling through his head
so he goes to this club spot where jyn
is at um one of his homies
he's already in a pissed off mood bad
mood he was he was already in the mind
state to kill
yeah and one of his homies said that jen
is here and jin disrespected him not
china mac per se but him
because something along the lines of his
girl is trying to
he was macking at this dude's girl or
some [ __ ] like that right so chinamak
was like all right let's run up on him
then
that's it that's all it [ __ ] took
cause he was in a bad [ __ ] mood
so saw him go to the bathroom took him
into a [ __ ] bathroom stall pushed him
up against the wall
and you know he had a gun on him but one
of his friends one of jyn's friends went
up behind china mac
he noticed it turned around whatever put
him on his knees or some [ __ ] like that
and he put the gun
what he specifically said was at like
the base of his skull
right here he pulled the trigger gun
jammed
got lucky yeah because if his gun didn't
jam he would have murdered him and he
would have been in jail for life right
that would have been
done and he he went to squeeze another
one and somehow his hand moved or some
[ __ ] shot the dude in the spine
and paralyzed him and then he was on the
run for about a [ __ ] year
and even before that he he apparently
wasn't he did a bid for three years
before that too
and this dude has been gangbanging since
he was like a little teen yeah because i
guess his dad was affiliated too
with like uh with like chinese mafia i
don't remember the the the set's name or
whatever what not but apparently it's
like affiliated
through like you know the og east coast
chinese mafia [ __ ]
um and then he he he got involved in a
gang
um that was actually rivaled to his
father's gang
to because he hated his [ __ ] dad
because his dad was never around so he
was like well [ __ ] it then i'ma join a
different gang and since then he was
like a hard and
hardened like gangster and criminal
which is kind of nuts and he takes that
and he puts it in the music
which a lot of people just because of
their thugs doesn't mean they can rap
yeah you know
for sure i mean like some people might
have that credibility but they're
garbage rappers
i don't know like or just garbage
whatever they're trying to do
um but yeah i'm kind of like uh
so somewhat familiar uh with that story
uh and it is kind of sad
for not just him but just artists of
kind of like
because you would consider him and like
some of these other artists
like around the same age more old heads
right yeah they're not the new
generation
and an old head trying to acclimate
himself or herself into the new
generation new way of things
it can be pretty daunting man just just
figuring out okay how do i record music
how do i get this [ __ ] out
that's that's a process in and of itself
figuring that out and now it's like how
do i make money off of this [ __ ]
what what what tools do i use how do i
use youtube how do i use instagram how
do i use snapchat
yeah and that could be
a real uphill battle to try to figure
that unless you got
like really well-versed people around
you who are very familiar with those
platforms who can help you out and i
feel like for him too
he has a lot of integrity right so in in
terms of him
loving hip hop and music he has that
traditional love for that genre so he
wants to pay homage and respect
for the way that he raps and the stuff
that he raps about right
problem with that that doesn't really
sell nowadays again old head yeah like
an overhead type of [ __ ] right yeah i
mean he did put out a track that he said
it wasn't very much like him but it was
probably in my personal opinion was one
of his best tracks he's ever put out so
there's this track called not that tough
and um he releases that track and then
he just says i'm done with music i'm
like well that was probably one of your
better tracks that you've ever done yeah
so he is leveling up but on the other
side he's like is he going to be like a
takashi 69
you know what i mean have you seen that
documentary about him on hulu but
takashi yeah no
it's it's [ __ ] nuts man yeah it's it
goes back into this whole idea of
it's not about artistry it's not about
music it's you doing whatever you can to
be famous for sure
and that is his whole stick right and so
even back in the day when
charlemagne the god and one at uh 106.5
he called them out he goes so what are
you done with this whole like facade
thing
right he says oh you think this shit's
not real it's not real but it wasn't so
when you go into this documentary first
of all the documentary opens up insane
so it's his documentarian he's in the
neighborhood and he's interviewing
the the projects that uh takashi 69 grew
up in yeah so he's talking to one of the
neighbors
and as he's asking me he goes do you
know who daniel is or whatever what not
and then one of the other neighbors
comes down he goes hey hey are you
[ __ ] talking about daniel
don't [ __ ] talk about daniel starts
cursing out the
the the dude that lives in the same but
he goes oh i'm just telling him i know
who he is he goes [ __ ] you
don't say [ __ ] and this other lady comes
down she goes what are you yelling him
for it's like he's talking about daniel
he goes tell him to get the [ __ ] out of
here
so i don't know what that whole shtick
is about but they get into this whole
process of of takashi 6 9's
start right obviously very troubled
childhood grew up
[ __ ] dirt poor had a kid at a super
young age
but one thing that everybody says that's
consistent is that
he always wanted to be famous and he was
doing
anything he could to make sure he was
famous yeah
and that was his stick so back in the
day he would wear shirts that were
really [ __ ] stupid like it would say
like uh i don't know
i eat [ __ ] on it and then people will
be like that's
this guy's [ __ ] crazy and he would
feed off of that oh it's like oh
if i wear a stupid shirt somebody's
gonna notice me cool i'll wear this
stupid
it's actually kind of sad yeah yeah you
know and so he would start doing crazier
[ __ ]
then he would start putting on the
rainbow hair colors and people like oh
you're the kid with the rainbow hair
so he goes oh if i keep doing dumb [ __ ]
and stupid stuff people are gonna
recognize me and recognize me
then he started doing music videos with
like you know at that time when
uh hood people were starting to you know
cling on to like japanese
uh anime [ __ ] right so he started naming
all his tracks
like popular phrases that you would see
in animes like uh one of his songs
called like shinigami right with death
god
yeah and then you know all these nerds
would start liking him and then all
these other like
he was trying to grab anything that he
[ __ ] could yeah do whatever he can
but what bit him on the ass was that he
kind of bit more than he could chew
oh i mean that's not a sustainable model
you know what i mean like he started
trolling real gangsters and [ __ ]
that was the part that blew my mind yeah
he would be in la and you know because
he's like this
so-called blood right he would start
trolling
these [ __ ] members right like real [ __ ]
members
and he would kind of like post a video
of him being at like a mall somewhere in
in
la right and like the dudes would see it
and they'd go after
you know go over there to find them but
then it turns out
he recorded that hours before and he
posted it on there like he was actually
there
so like he would troll these dudes and
then they would go looking for him and
you know i'm like oh dude when he
started doing [ __ ] like that i'm like
okay man
you're not you're not gonna last bro
like you you're playing with fire
constantly now it's weird too and and
you know what the sad thing is when i
was watching this documentary
it was also a reflection of what matters
to the youth
right and it's it's not about creating
things it's just about
what can i do so anybody will look at me
and this is generally where this
generation is going
yeah and it's very and highly evident in
takashi 69
because even after they found out like
number one he's not really a thug he was
just a troll
that kind of just was sucking his own
dick too hard yeah
right because what happened was he
almost got murdered once for it
and then after that he went he was going
to go to jail for the racketeering and
all this other [ __ ] which he was not
prepared for right he was never a thug
he was never a gangster yeah so
you know him playing up that part he was
supposed to go to jail for [ __ ] life
yeah and then what does he do he rats
everybody out which goes to show
he's not really about that life right
but still
gets millions of spins people still [ __ ]
with them and they think that it's cool
so this these young kids are going to
follow suit well he's like it's meme
culture
you know what i mean he was like a
living breathing meme right
uh but i'll give you an example of that
type of mindset
actually working positively somebody
like mr beast
on youtube his whole thing was the same
thing i just want to be
a famous youtuber yeah whatever it takes
for me to be able to get that
i'm just gonna try different so when he
started out he had no
like uh purpose in terms of what his
personality or what his thing was gonna
be as a youtuber
he's just like i'm just gonna try
different things but before we continue
this podcast let's talk about one of our
amazing sponsors
care of my friends if you have not heard
of care of where have you been it is a
wellness brand that makes it easy to
maintain
your health goals with a customized
vitamin plan that helps you feel
amazing all of kara's products are
formulated with good for you clean
ingredients that are
backed by science care of is super
transparent about the research and
sourcing behind each of their products
which help you relax because you don't
have to worry about
anything your recommendations come in
daily individually
wrapped packets that are perfect for
getting back into
the roux team see february can still be
a fresh start for the new year and your
resolutions don't
have to be big and even small impactful
changes are just as important
like adding a daily vitamin to help
support your energy sleep or fitness to
target those goals whether in the short
or long term i love care of all i had to
do was take a very simple quiz
and they kind of diagnosed what i needed
for my vitamin supplementation based on
the stuff
that i personally care about so it's
super awesome
it's really easy to do you have nothing
to lose but to improve your life
so for all my genius brain listeners
make sure you get this deal for
50 off your first care of order go to
takecareof.com and enter code genius50
once again for
50 off your first care of order go to
takecareof.com
and enter code genius50 to get that deal
today
and improve your health or to maintain a
healthy lifestyle
with him he was a little bit more
business-minded about it like okay
i did this live streaming counting to
100 000 in real time and it got this
many views
okay this type of stuff works so i'm
gonna start focusing on this type of
thing
and then eventually he kind of got into
the whole philanthropy stick right
yeah i mean he it seems like he actually
enjoys
giving yeah to people so i'm i'm not
gonna go as far as calling it a schtick
i mean i i'm pretty sure he there's a
genuine sense of like
wanting to give too but it also happens
to get him a ton of views
yeah and then he just kept refining
refining refining and landed on
basically the model of where he's at now
is doing all these
crazy things having to do with giving
money away or giving
you know items away or whatever and two
look at how many views he gets man he
drops a video and like within
a couple of days he's at like five
million views within a week he's
like 10 15 million views you know every
video he drops gets double digit million
views
it's not like he what he does now is
that uh all the stuff that he gives away
is sponsored now
yeah yeah so it doesn't even come out of
his own pocket yeah so he's he's been
doing that too
like the whole million dollar thing i
think was sponsored by uh honey
right yeah that uh cash back or whatever
app um so yeah he does get a i mean he's
transparent about that that he
sponsors are what helps him to do these
bigger and better things
but then there are times too when he
does do it out of his own pocket
yeah but whatever the case is like
that's a
that's a good example of how doing
whatever it takes to get famous
puts somebody in the right path but
i would say that i mean it's a lottery
to get
big in and of itself but then to go in a
positive way
within that that's like you know one in
a billion
like i would think too because you know
back in the day
if you were kind of outed out as
somebody who was fake or kind of lived a
fake life like your career was done
it's like yeah i'm not gonna [ __ ] with
this dude he's not even about that [ __ ]
yeah but it kind of shows where values
lie it's like well he's
he's it doesn't matter you know like
we'll we'll still [ __ ] with them no
matter what yeah
he's still getting the same views yeah
like a part of me looks at that i'm like
this kid won like he won yeah
no i mean that's the thing though that's
that's kind of like the culture we're in
right now
yeah is people people don't give a [ __ ]
to really like confirm things they might
hear oh yeah you know that dude's a fake
[ __ ]
he's a phony whatever you know i'm not
even gonna pay attention to it
yeah i mean i'm not i'm not gonna fact
check it i'm just gonna
[ __ ] with it because i like his music or
i like what he does or
he's a wild guy he's very entertaining
you know whatever the case
is that's where we're at that's where
we're at and like you just brought up
maybe back in
like let's say the 90s you got a rapper
who's
actually you know what though
we got we got plenty of uh artists too
who
uh pretended to be
kind of like about that gang life and
you know gang culture
but it was more of like they're playing
up you know that that whole thing
right i mean that's existed since i
would say like
probably the 90s yeah yeah yeah but they
weren't
as i guess crazy about it
like a guy like takashi he went above
and beyond with
everything right yeah um
so you know that's i
to in a sense i feel like as always
that's exactly what marketing is right
it's about figuring out how are we gonna
market this artist to an audience that
we think
he'll or she or he will hit with and
that's how you kind of upsell something
oh
he you know he's from a bad neighborhood
maybe we can upsell the fact that he's a
gangster
you know he has affiliation his family
members or whatever so that artist
himself i mean i don't want to name any
names particularly
yeah you know i i'm happy with my life
so um but certain artists
like later on in their career like even
their own moms would say oh yeah
you know he was never this bad he got
worse after he started rapping
you know after he started getting no i
remember somebody calling out paul wall
about that [ __ ] because he went to like
a private christian school he was like a
super
cool and all of a sudden he had the
grills in his mouth and everything i was
like that
i forgot who called them out but paul
wall was one of them too and and that's
when you would say
it's like kind of like appropriating
right you're appropriating
like poor people's life yeah and that
that culture when it's really sad
but so that you can sell records you
know uh
and you can get more i guess views and
hits you know what's nuts like
even the concept of like the whole
cultural appropriation thing
it became a really i didn't realize how
big of a deal it's been since
for a while like even since uh vanilla
ice like there was a specific
interview that vanilla ice was going i
think was arsenio hall that was
interviewing and he kind of asked him
about
what do you think about people saying
that you're you know that you're
basically culturally appropriating like
black culture and making it profitable
for you
because these aren't like new issues
like this is stuff that's been there
since back in the day yeah because
basically what
what was brought up is like you're
basically a biter of mc hammer and
you're
taking his shine and you're making money
off of his stuff right and then you know
vanilla ice respondents like i can't
control what i do like that's just them
if they think that and this is what it
is
but this has been a topic that's been
going on for a very [ __ ] long time
yeah because it seems like all the stuff
seems really uh recent like oh
people haven't brought this stuff up at
all but it's not true like when i just
looked it up i was like oh
vanilla ice went through that [ __ ] it's
been around for since you know when i
was a little kid
yeah no it's it's been around for a long
time and it's not
it's not just people appropria
appropriating black culture either
i mean asian culture i mean like every
culture
gets appropriated in some sense right uh
it's just that i feel like the big focus
here in america has
when it comes to appropriation has been
about appropriating black culture
because
there's so much entertainment here the
entertainment industry is here
but then you know you take like okay
well so if
somebody is getting like asian tattoos
on their body and they don't even know
what the [ __ ] it means right
that's appropriation right oh that [ __ ]
like i forgot who jeremy lin said that
[ __ ] too but jeremy lin
because he had the cornrows in his head
and i forgot which basketball player
came at him
and he was like jeremy shouldn't do that
[ __ ] because he's appropriating black
culture and he's like well what's up
with the chinese tattoos on your arms
right
no exactly exactly that's what i'm
saying
that's good yeah no exactly and it's not
just with the tattoos that's just a you
know easy example to understand
but you know when it comes to like asian
culture appropriation
right no one's [ __ ] giving a [ __ ]
about that
no one's no one's saying anything about
that you know what i mean like when when
uh for example
like um people here americans will wear
like the the japanese like uh
kind of like the oh the girl yeah yeah
yeah yeah
where's people screaming appropriation
there right
that's what i'm saying it just kind of
ties in with the whole
violence against these asian elders too
is that asian people are not
looked at seriously like race and
culture is such a
it's it's kind of an exhausting topic in
this country specifically
like this country everything that has to
do with anything has to deal with
race now like it's so funny because the
idea
of what we ideally want from each other
is that
a race shouldn't even matter right but
people can't stray away from it
they almost use it as a crutch for
themselves right and obviously there's
like a deep-rooted history with
black americans in this in this country
right so that's obviously a separate
topic
but the hard part is is like how are you
going to level up from this right not
just black everybody in this country i'm
talking about americans in general
it's like if you want everybody to be to
look at you just based on
the character of who you are then
you're gonna have to move past looking
at everything as a race issue
right and once again i'm not talking
about the recent events that happened in
this country with the whole blm stuff
this is a separate topic
but i think now everything is becoming
so racially charged and everybody's
becoming so hyper sensitive
those lines between what's what can be
said appropriately in a positive or
negative manner
nobody knows yeah right like for example
too like if you describe
like this is a funny ass sketch right
where it was like a mad tv sketch
where uh somebody was in a retail store
and this lady she got helped out
by a black dude and obviously like when
you're in a retail store and you get
helped out by somebody
when you're at the cash register they
want to know who helped you out so they
can give them credit or whatever or they
get a cut of the sale
yeah yeah yeah all right and then she
goes oh who helped you out and she goes
oh the uh
he's tall
everybody has brown eyes like what else
he is he might like hip-hop
you know in that type of situation too
that is actually something that's very
real
like it would it's very uncomfortable
for somebody to say oh it's like oh that
black dude over there helped me out yeah
right because like what you mean black
dude yeah right
now so that begs the question then have
we become
have has our american culture and
society become two pieces
too soft oh i've a hundred percent
believe it's way too [ __ ] soft yeah
like you could walk away and be offended
by
everything now yeah i feel the same bro
and honestly two it's okay for you to
feel offended i think the problem is is
how much you think people should change
because of your preference
is the problem that i had it's your
specific presence
you could feel a certain way about it
and you could talk about it or whatever
but the idea of canceling somebody for
all this other stuff oh yeah
it's it's it's hard like i i get it too
right
because sometimes i get caught up in
that type of fervor where i'm like
you know what [ __ ] this guy they
shouldn't make a single dime or whatever
but at the same time like i still want
people to be able to like express
themselves and say the things that they
want to say
without having to feel like everything
that they do is going to get canceled
yeah right and it's just this world
where people just
don't want to feel bad ever like they
never want to feel bad
like [ __ ] you're going to [ __ ] feel
bad all the time you can't control that
[ __ ]
it's not fair yeah it's not fair for
specifically for creatives and artists
right because specifically great art
pushes boundaries
all the time whether it's paintings
whether it's drawings
music stand-up comedy whatever the [ __ ]
that it is creative writing
it's always going to push boundaries and
if you always want to be comfortable
there's no growth in that
so how do you expect artists to push
push forward like stand-up comics like
they're gonna say some [ __ ] up [ __ ]
right
it's going to happen i have said [ __ ]
up [ __ ] multiple times
but in order for them to work on their
set and work on things
they cannot be stopped from doing this
material or
they're just never going to create good
things it's just going to be the same
[ __ ] that you see all the time
dave chappelle is dave chappelle for a
reason louis c.k is louis c.k for a
reason minus
you know jacking off masturbating in
front of people
you know no i agree man i agree it's
um because a lot of the times art can be
social commentary too
so if anything you're kind of holding up
a mirror and saying you know a certain
thing about it right
and not to mention art can also be open
for interpretation yeah then when it's
like no
you cannot say what you think and say
what you
feel uh because those are off limits now
yeah if you do that we're gonna [ __ ]
cancel you like
in the in mass we're gonna cancel you
yeah
and you know i feel like yeah [ __ ]
this
culture society maybe the younger
generation
and people a lot of people in in america
these days have become very [ __ ]
sensitive and like
very trigger-happy they're just married
to the idea that they shouldn't feel any
pain
like what the [ __ ] are you talking about
like how do you live like that yeah well
and having that mentality in that mind
state too is gonna set you up for
[ __ ] failure
because every time you're offended every
time you're hurt you're going to expect
other people to patch you on the back
and that's not [ __ ] it's not exact
that ain't that ain't life
that's not [ __ ] life man i'm sorry
man like you're going to have to just
figure out how to [ __ ] take the the
hits and punches sometimes you know what
i mean
it's like they're trying to mold this
world into a pain-free world
and it's never gonna be like that not in
america anyway yeah
what i mean or just anywhere in general
people are gonna say stupid [ __ ] like
you
and especially if you're on the internet
people are saying even more stupid [ __ ]
it actually makes me want to create
troll accounts just so i can say
offensive [ __ ] now
just to get people to get used to it
yeah you know well i
should i'm [ __ ] man the the youtube
comment section i always say is the
cesspool of america we see
everything across the spectrum there you
know from like straight up racism
to like just straight up idiocracy like
everything um and then i see that and
i'm like you know what
there's a good chunk of america that's
like that you know there's people out
there that are like that
uh but the sensitivity thing man i just
feel like people are way too sensitive
now and it's like
really is not that big of a [ __ ] deal
dude learn to learn to [ __ ] be able
to joke about things
even something like everybody wants to
be like this social justice warrior
nobody even wants to look at intent
sometimes right so
the other day i was looking at a tweet
and this person
wanted to put this other person on blast
right
and this specific individual asked
this young asian girl a question that
yeah culturally it was a little
insensitive
but the intent wasn't bad right before
we continue this podcast let's talk
about our amazing sponsor
i p vanish now if you don't know who
ipvanish
is most likely you are browsing the
internet in an unsafe
manner you can use a vpn on your
computers tablet phones and even things
like your fire stick when you're
streaming media when
you use a vpn all your data is encrypted
what you're reading what you're
searching what you're watching whatever
it is you're doing ipvanise is just 349
a month or 27.99 a year yes it's that
cheap you need to protect your online
privacy and
security so go to ipvanish.com brain
claim your
65 savings they have plans starting at
349 a month or 27.99 a year
this is the time to sign up with our
discount and their current promotional
offerings
you can get a vpn for 65 off the usual
offering
ipvanish is the best of the best even
rated 4.7 out of 5 on trustpilot and
that's more than
6 000 reviews show these guys some love
remember it's ipvanish.combrain to get
the deal and start protecting yourself
online and so it was something that was
written in chinese
and asked her it's like hey do you know
what this means like could you help me
out and then you know she kind of goes
off on her like i'm not
i'm not chinese you shouldn't even ask
people but you know all this other stuff
it's like
hold on a second and you know screen
caps it puts it up like yo this girl is
so stupid before he even asked me this
is 2021 you shouldn't even do this type
of stuff it's like
number one that girl is your fan she
didn't do it because she
hates you right it could have just been
an honest mistake it's an
honest [ __ ] mistake it's going to
happen if you keep doing [ __ ] like that
people just won't ever [ __ ] with it
right look at the context though yeah
right
like it wasn't hey ching chong can you
exactly
hey my she [ __ ] thought it's all the
same [ __ ] people don't know things right
there's stuff that you don't know about
other people's culture
the difference was that she came at you
in a very nice way she just didn't know
it was an opportunity for you to educate
that person or just
you know in a very kind way and now that
person [ __ ] hates you right now that
person's gonna go around
[ __ ] hating asian people right and
that's your bad so it's like in that
situation
ignorance sure racism that's a stretch
right yeah that's a that's a really far
stretch but so like
if it's coming from a place of ignorance
and it's not coming from
like it's not a hostile type of
ignorance
yeah you can take that moment to be like
hey
you know you can't if you really need to
say something you can't assume
you know that all asians or chinese or
whatever
right um i'm not whatever you think i am
and i don't know what this says and the
story right
i would have just wrote like lol what
the [ __ ] are you talking about
or i would have just said some funny
[ __ ] yeah i was like oh it actually
means that you have aids yeah it just
translates
yeah it means you have a bumpy [ __ ]
that's what that means and you're
walking around with a tattoo this is
this bumpy [ __ ] on you yeah but that's
that's a that's a really that's what i'm
saying like that sensitive knee-jerk
reaction you know what i mean yeah it's
this idea that you have to just
constantly hurt people just to get them
to understand
that was a fan like it was a fan of this
person's content yeah and instead
of taking that time to be like hey you
made an honor you think that person is
trying to offend you
this person likes you yeah like
genuinely likes you and you clearly went
out of your way to read out of your
hundreds of dm's right
single this person out right which is a
little weird you know to me in the first
place it's like are you looking for your
dms to find like angry things
like to be angered about yeah it's uh
i don't know man i i don't i don't know
why or how uh it's kind of shifted into
this direction
maybe maybe because uh getting to be
anonymous
online it played a he plays a huge part
to that because now people can like
virtue signal and just like kind of say
whatever the [ __ ] they want
everybody's a [ __ ] tough guy dude
yeah with with a no
no like repercussion um and
that could probably be the reason why it
kind of shifted that way
but i look at it i'm like man a bunch of
sensitive [ __ ] you know i
i come from a different time in a
different era where
you know we joked and said things that
might not be
considered appropriate these days but
the intention was never
meant to be like a hurtful thing like
towards a group of people or a type of
people or whatever
yeah now it's like yeah
oh my god how can you say that in 2021
it's like they're flipping the [ __ ] out
over everything it's like you don't have
to do it that way
there are things to be angry about and
there's other things that you should
that you don't have to
like me too that that's a serious thing
yeah like a lot of these [ __ ]
who who were you know abusing their
power
to to do things to people
but then that kind of went overboard too
like in a sense of like anything and
everything that could be
remotely close to being perceived as an
abuse of power in a certain way
is like you are immediately [ __ ]
canceled right
but there's like degrees of that [ __ ]
too you know we talked about this before
like louis c.k masturbating in front of
people yeah that's weird
yeah that's weird but it's not
it's not the same as like [ __ ]
roofing somebody and then like raping
this person
i think i mean everybody had like a
different take on it because the room
was split 50 50 on that topic because of
like
um it's like the the the argument
against louis is that
beca he used his power over this person
to masturbate in front of her right but
then the other side of the argument was
louis wasn't threatening he wasn't he
didn't
verbally say like if you walk out this
room you'll never open for me ever again
right right right and he asked he
actually asked for consent
and you agreed upon it
and you stood there and you watched him
you watched i mean it's not like
as soon as he puts his hand on his dick
he nuts there's a period there where he
needs to work up to it
and so it was like it was like a weird
thing it was like you know i understood
both sides of the argument but it was
kind of odd too because in my mind when
i first thought of it i was like this
will [ __ ]
make this fool made this girl stay here
and watch him and they're like no he
jacked off yeah and then she was next to
the door and then she stood and watched
him like a perv
bro bro bro there there was enough time
during that process
to to let that marinade and think uh you
know i don't really like this i don't
like what i'm seeing right now turn
around and leave like i said i
understand the whole like power
argument thing but i guess like for for
me anyways when i think about that it
was like
i don't i don't know like i don't know
what that feels like so if a dude
i could only speak for myself if a girl
just started fingering herself in front
of
me
like what the [ __ ] are you doing like
put that [ __ ] disgusting mouse trap
away you nasty [ __ ]
what's wrong with you you'll never work
in this town again
neither will you i'll pick up my
let's play this game yeah no but i mean
that's the thing it's like
you know i feel like maybe maybe it was
an abuse of power
but maybe he's just sick in the head
like that and he has that type of like
you know perversion like where whether
or not he was in that place of power he
would have done that anyway
you know what i mean it's not
necessarily the need to flex
power it's the need to show somebody
that hey i'm gonna message he definitely
has he has a weird preference for that
[ __ ] yeah yeah
it's so odd too cause louis ck would
talk about that [ __ ] in a stand up
i'm like oh that [ __ ] wasn't standard
that's just real life huh yeah at least
this motherfucker's honest as [ __ ] huh
yeah damn well everybody that wraps up
this episode of the genius brain podcast
you could catch us every thursdays and
sundays uh you can
catch ed at ed too
i always i will sit at park vp
and if you guys want to cop the gear
it's at secret society
you can see that uh on instagram and you
can go ahead and go on the website and
check that out
and we will see you all next time all
right y'all peace peace